several recent deadly incidents around
the country have shed the light on law
enforcement's use of force
today joe moeller got a look inside
metro's facility designed to help
officers prepare
for real world situations
i geared up this is your patrol vehicle
got briefed on the replicated real-life
emergency call
you guys arrive and then you can be the
backup
i responded to reports of a man with a
frying pan a knife and who was
potentially on drugs
sir if you don't drop that knife we're
going to hit you with a beanbag i was
guided through the appropriate use of
force for this type of situation where
an armed person was approaching
[Applause]
in this case it was my non-lethal shot
that allowed officers to put the
individual into custody
the point is to put them in these these
static and controlled
training environments to induce some
stress and work with them to work
through that stress to solve the problem
adam stubbs is a police training
sergeant
the metro use of forced reality-based
training facility was created back in
2011.
every year the department takes new
real-life situations from around the
country and recreates it here for
practice for officers
to give them updates and also reinforce
and review the tactics they're already
using out in the field just to reinforce
good habits
and to review new updates to our policy
and updates to case law
after the death of george floyd nevada
lawmakers banned neck restraints
attacked
officers are no longer taught we also
give verbal commands
if you don't drop that knife i'm going
to hit you with this bean bag it's going
to hurt
officers are trained on the best options
for de-escalating situations and what
type of tools are best in potentially
deadly scenarios
i think it's important the public also
sees just how we do train
and why we train for what we do the more
practice the better
stubs says the hours put in here could
end up saving a life
out on the streets training goes on here
at this facility just about every day
every officer here in las vegas goes
through about 20 hours of training
every year reporting near downtown las
vegas joe mohler eight news now